it's a great pleasure for us to give a
warm welcome to to Jack Ma thank you
I it's my great honor and I was invited
about mountains ago and it's I did not
expect this people say this is a very
sensitive sensitive time for me to talk
because about a yahoo about all the
above about this and that but the
promise of the promise are come today
any questions you have I will answer
every question you have all right so
I've been here for 15 days and I planned
to spend one year here and nobody knows
my company did not know that I'm gonna
spend our year here I guess people ask
why you are here are you ready for
getting Yahoo No
everybody was very sensitive when I say
I'm going to spend one year there and I
just come here I'm tied to tied in a
posture sixteen years I start my
business and I started 1994-5 Internet
and I got crazy about the Internet give
up my job in the teaching and like I
call myself like a blind man riding on
the back of blind Tigers jumping around
Stu kicking and still surviving and then
join the government organization for
sixteen mouse and not successful at
Alibaba 1999 and we build up the Alibaba
we are lucky enough to have the Taba we
have the a leap a we have a li cloud
computing and so many things are after
12 years I say I need some time to rest
especially this year was so difficult
for me I did not expect I prepare for 12
year was in China called upon minion
this is our 12 year for Alibaba at the
beginning of the year we have the the
you know moving for the Alibaba rp2 be
CEO because of the custom cheating
things and then we have the Ali pay and
about the V ie
I still don't know what the VI is right
and then we have we have the the Ali
Taobao separated into four parts so many
things that really make me feel tight
and I said well why not give up one year
because next year is my personal per
minion which is could be much more
difficult
well this C was very tough and difficult
I believe next year is going to be
tougher and more difficult and more
complexed so I got ready for that and I
knew think I need a rest so in order to
for another three four years how to work
it because this three years is not my
job if something wrong criticized this
president of top of C of Alibaba and a
leap it is their fault because three
years therefore three years later
something wrong my fault so I come here
and I will spare most
timing estates and then thinking
relaxing and yes the two days ago I pick
up my golf and here and just relax so
nothing about the things people think
about so we are very lucky company and
there's no chance that we survived I
don't have any sort of backgrounds a
rich father or strong ankles so and I
not 99 I came to Silicon Valley looking
for venture capitalists I talked to a
lot of magic capitalists and I remember
a few days we're going to drive by by
the man lo park right
I was hours rejected by so many venture
capitalists when I talk about Alibaba
starlets they look at me strange what
Alibaba what they're talking about but I
I went back to China with nothing no
money nobody invested in me but I full
of confidence I saw the American Dreams
at that time 1999 I walked on this high
expressway you know the high express
with every evening full of cars and in
the parks of the of the companies and
Sunday weekends full of cars and people
working day and night and now this is
something I believe it's going to
happening in China without getting any
venture capitalist but I think I went
back China which the American Dreams and
we started the business there and after
12 years you know a lot of things happen
we would build up the b2b and nobody
believed the b2b would work because the
b2b at that time was good but our rebar
I don't know stood there yeah arriba
arriba calm broad vision and commerce
one and all these are very famous b2b
companies people say how can you do b2b
in China because b2b in the USA they
focus on big companies they focus on
buyers
and we believe there's no big companies
in China and I don't see there are big
companies in in a short term that with
China we have a lot of become because
big companies only SOE SOE they do not
need ecommerce they need is government
policy right so we focus a small
business we because we believe China the
small business the private sectors are
the future so we focus on that and the
b2b in the USA focus of buyers they want
help the buyers to save the cost to save
the time we believe don't teach the SME
don't teach you the small business how
to save the cost because they know much
better than you do you should help them
how to make money so we focus on helping
small business we focus on helping them
to make money to sell things abroad very
difficult to do business at that time
but after 12 years we got more than 58
million small business around the world
using our services that that model is
not very sexy compared to 10 7 by do we
do not make that much money
like I like online gaming's but we can
sleep well in the evening because the
money we make not online gaming's the
money we make the helping small business
to survive to get business opportunities
which I feel very proud of that and
today as always I never feel proud that
how much money we make I feel proud how
much impact we can help the others
especially small business before the
history of Internet no company can help
over 50 million SMEs today we are trying
and I feel proud of that this is the
first company and people say Jack if you
make Alibaba successful that means you
you are pulling a million tons of ship
on the top of the Himalaya and I say yes
we will carry that thing down and we did
the second company is called the Taobao
and everybody say oh my god you're
competing with eBay
I see why not China needs an e-commerce
site and build up the China market takes
efforts takes time and takes great
effort you really want to build up
something so at that time people say
there's no chance well if you never
tried don't you how do you know there's
no chance
so we tried and I said we if they are
the sharks in the ocean we are the
crocodiles in the Yangtze River never
fight in the ocean let's fight Oh
Yangtze River
it was difficult it's a lot of fun
and we survived they got a 90% market
share at that time today for c2c Peter's
one we're like a 90% market share and
lucky just lucky um a lot of things can
be discussed in the future today
people always write about the successful
stories about Alibaba and I and I really
don't think we are so smart we made so
many mistakes
we were so stupid that time so I think
someday the book I personally really
want to write about I such that there's
Alibaba 1001 mistakes these are the
things these are the things people
should remember people should learn if
you want to learn how the people of the
other people succeed it's very difficult
there are a lot of lucky things right
there but if you want to learn if you
learn how people feel you will benefit a
lot and I always relied to read those
books talking about how people feel
because look if you look into it any
company that feel the reasons why they
feel almost the same and that really
matters
so Taba succeed and then we have the a
leap a because everybody say China or no
credit system banking is terrible
Logistics terrible and how can two
ecommerce I never tell to just like
today I come here not we said app2 was
that my business I'm not coming here to
sell your business sell my business
because I don't have stocks to sell to
you guys but I think because China is
not a good debt logistic not good our
credit system not good at a banking
system that's why we need the
Entrepreneurship that's why we go we
should go in the Butte the map so I
believe there's no you bit it up later
this become the standard of China and I
believe China needs that six years ago I
came to the states I told the USA all
day and say I believe five years later
China will have more Internet users than
the USA people say no I say well you
have only three hundred minute
population China 1.3 billion right for
you guys to have four hundred million
Internet users without anybody dying
keep on having babies you take 50 years
when you're 5 years it's just a timing
issues right so let's waited to see
today with more users and today people
say while you're buying capability is
low let's see about five years later
five years later today people bus only
span of 200 MB per day per month five
years later these guys will spend 2,000
and we have patience we are young you
know I'm bowed but my people only 26
average age they're young let's wait for
the future so Ali pay was just a very
that time people say it's a stupid
escrow services right Jon wants buy
things from Steven John doesn't know why
that why the money and Steve does not
want to give the products so we open a
can to say why the money to us if you're
happy with why the money not happy
return products return the money people
see how stupid the model is well we
don't care whether stupid are not stupid
we care where the customer wanted or not
rather really meet the need of the
customers it is stupid but after seven
years we have more than six hundred
million users register users in China
using that so stupid the things if you
improve it every day it's going to be
very smart and we believe that so today
it is good and it's growing and it's
like a PayPal but we are bigger than
PayPal right now on transaction wise and
the last and most important is ally
cloud computing and not like the other
companies days talk about a leak they
talk about cloud computing they want to
sell you the hardware softwares we have
nothing to sell you we just want
computing our own data because the data
we have from the SM is because the data
is we have the consumers from Taobao
data is from ali car pay so we want we
believe in the future the world is going
to be the data processing world
how we can share the data with the
others in a in a in a great way
right so that's the thing that the
business about it's not that good yet
but it is very profitable the whole
company looks healthy so we are very
preciate we are the company from thanks
there's no chance we can win now we
survive I think we always ask our own
question why we still working so hard I
talked to my colleague one day and he
said Jack I never know that in my life I
can do that much second I never know
that the things I'm doing at that
meaningful to the society and third I
never know that life is dense at heart
we work day and night even now we work
day and night I guess
so thinner stretching I understand life
is not easy with you proud because we
are changing China it's not how much
money you make when you see I think
seven ten years ago when I walk on the
street people thank me because my
Alibaba b2b help them to get orders
across the ocean today when I walk on
the street the young people say Jack
thank you very much I hope my wife and I
open a small shop on top off we make we
made us surviving we had a great in
common you know this is meaningful thing
we make the credit means money years ago
if you have a great record a credit
trust but you're not you're not rich
today if you have a good record on
Taobao you get a rich because people do
business with those people with good rap
record we're teaching consumers to smart
people say Jack I bought something so
cheap I'm terrible is that a fake
product yes we do fake products
everywhere
but we spend most of the efforts in
China 50% of the people in Taobao
they're focusing on checking the
intellectual property issues but there's
a bottle wine
the cost is only nine dollars but people
buy on the street is $300 why is that
the channels the advertisement the TV
shows why consumers should pay that much
so we cut that and we make things
changing so tell the consumers say this
t-shirt you buy on top of maybe 30 to
$15 you're buying a shop $150 not
because top are selling cheaper because
that shop sell too expensive we should
teach the consumers to be smart and a
third very important we saw so many
factories in China especially in Kanto
they are not company they're not even
the factory they just om they just to
sell things they just manufacture it
they don't know who are selling for them
and they don't know who are the
customers so anything come they are in
trouble so we should tell them
manufacturers you have to contact the
consumers yourself you have to sell
yourself serve yourself then this is a
real business otherwise it's just a
workshop and we're changing that and I
feel proud and we are it's not about
money
as we believe when you have one minute
I'm be or 1 million US dollars you're
rich man when you have 10 million US
dollars
you are in trouble you worry about
increasing I am being you know you study
invest you get into trouble when you
have 1 billion that's not your money
it's the society's trust like the
shareholder the people believe you can
spend these monies smarter than the
government you can spend the money than
the others
so they give you the trust how can you
do this trust how can you you know treat
this trust too well and I think we are
facing this challenge
and the product for Alibaba is not the
people it's not it's not the service
it's the people the employees the
colleagues the average age of the
company is 26 years old and we are
facing so many challenges guys I never
realized that one of the key government
offices of another country visit to the
maser Jack oh my god you have [ __ ] 300
million users on Taobao and the popular
so much bigger than my pantry yeah it is
difficult any policy we're making we get
in a big trouble because people say this
is pretty good if some people complain
it's just like a government policy
making and those people who are making
policies their average age 26 we have
never met these kind of things if we
change you know like a search engine the
normal search engine you who pays better
who licks on the top we believe we
should put the trust record the credible
record on that and then we put that a
lot of people say we will demonstrate
200 people last year came to our company
demonstrate say Jack you change the
policy
you got a pipe you know but I say if it
is right let's do it and this is the
world we're changing and now today what
what we need is not a pure programs not
service people I product manager what we
need is some sociologists economists and
those guy who make the principle the
policies so we are facing a lot of
challenge challenges but we feel proud
because I believe in a 21st century if
you want to be a successful company you
have to learn how to solve a problem of
the society instead of catching one or
two opportunities it is so easy to catch
opportunities and I'm not bragging I
think today after after 12 years jumping
around I find that making money is very
simple
but making sustainable money and
responsible to the society improve the
world
meanwhile make him a lot of money is
very difficult this is what we are
trying and we think China because of
internet is improving and three years
later I'm preparing for that today
people say ah China stop internet stop
going down that because of the V ie
because of what there's no I think look
at the US economy
this is their facing big challenges
Europe probably go nowhere right
China anything that happens today in the
US and Europe is going to happen in
China three years later China is going
to face a big challenge in three four
years later and if you know something
bad is coming get ready for it instead
of screaming now instead of complaining
and as internet companies we have to
take a responsibility and my job I'm not
politician I'm not speaking for
government I'm speaking for myself for
our own business
speak for my customers 15 minutes mes
and eight million top out power sellers
how they should survive three years
later this is something I want to come
here in the States
learn how about mark say I'm going to
create a jobs how he did that any
mistake we should learn from it and
three years later let's solve it our way
this is why I'm here so I think you all
have a lot of pressures am I ready to
answer any questions you have because I
don't know what what to talk about later
because I'm just here it's just a free
talk right thank you very much any
question you have
take other side thanks
well mr. ma you brought it up first so
I'm going to make you answer your own
questions and be honest about it are you
gonna buy Yahoo good question yes we are
very interested in that we are very
interested in Yahoo because our asset
Alibaba Group is so important to Yahoo
and Yahoo assets also very very
important to us to the Internet users
and to the industries so yeah we are
interested in and also all the peas and
all the serious buyers they already
talked to us and they should talk to us
more have you made the initial approach
to them but about have you made the
initial approach to them about buying
them
I just assure that we are very
interested in right now thank you
hey Jeff actually I'm not gonna ask that
tough question I was actually encouraged
by Joe this morning and he said that
anything about the sinner mode and I VI
e mode and just ask Jack and the he'll
be the right person to answer answer of
all these questions and okay seriously
this is a question that I know that PRC
government has adopted the national
security review system against the MLA
merged and acquired the PRC company by
the foreign and come fight foreign
companies so on my question is how do
you view the impact of the scoops
scrutiny by the PRC government and
specifically do you think that's gonna
add adversely impact for the PRC
complaint go off so I peel again get
finance from from former bra okay so
yeah it's more aggressive probably I'm
sorry for those
I was answer this question in Chinese
which probably more specific any English
translation property you know people can
help because so many top people talking
about a VI I'm got confused I spend a
lot of time these days understand what
the hell is that okay in English right I
just refer her to English first VI e is
a great innovation and I believe it's a
great innovation ten years ago seen a
model it's a great it helped China grow
on the internet and all the other
high-tech industries which we Alibaba
also benefit a lot and I don't see the
government is going to take that thing
down
I never feel that and I don't know why
people worry so much about that but some
sensitive areas some industry some
sectors like finance like I don't know
what else these things the government
have concerns about VI structure which I
understand and we should support for
example if anybody want to get a bank
banking license in China like a 20 25
percent foreign capital own if you
across that any nation we're against it
so VI structure I do not see any
government say well I'm going to shut
that thing down what worried about we
should put this thing on the only a few
days ago I read in an article about a
shotgun tune right you know so sure guns
in the guy cooks the feet haha but sure
dancing the dagger me sway or see eg a
samsung chunk with a khadeem shotgun
turnitin touching awkward zap uncle John
Houser un cerdo we got make this VI e
really legal
as parent this is the power of internet
making sure if it is good after 10 years
testing it is good why not open if any
tiny sensitive area that you're not
comfortable
join us discuss about that so I don't
know people say well something wrong
with the ollie pay ah
I'm honored right because of that we
open the ie because tell the truth we're
government the PBOC the meetinghouse
look helmet was do you Ally pay has a
foreign cap - I have to tell the truth
guys do you agree if the government say
do you have foreign capital I say no but
I have this this one work because we are
getting bigger right just like today if
I come to say I want to buy ah I want to
buy the PayPal do you think the US does
not have any proof oh they will
even if Yahoo right so we have to be
fear it's not that big issue its gesture
it's just err let's face it open it
discussing it and I don't see the
government is going to shut that down
alright I hope I'll answer your question
now hi jack
I think we haven't been seeing each
other for more than 10 years oh yeah
look terrific today so I'm ready
I believe you went through a lot of
difficult things in past 10 years
so you also mention about you one day
you will write a book so my question is
would you like to share just one thing
with us first and you would do
differently differently ah you know for
something one thing ok yeah ok
all right Thank You Michelle right
Michelle tanner
thank you yeah we know lot not see for
10 years yeah we go through a lot of
tough days if today when something
smooth are just a few uncomfortable
that's that true in the US and called a
very paranoid I am yeah but the mistake
we made a lot for Yahoo China I think
when we acquired a Yahoo China if if
people ask me well that we would do it
again yes I will but whether we would do
it in this way no I want we would do a
much better
smart way because we had no any
experience of acquisition especially
acquire an Internet company and we made
a lot of mistakes that and that helped
us today so when you ask me about
whether I'm interested in Yahoo yes of
course I think we are probably one of
the very few companies really understand
Yahoo USA very well because of that and
people say well Yahoo China is terrible
how could you still talk about that I
mean terrible running no it's not
terrible running we solve problems four
years ago so we cut Yahoo China if we do
not we would have died today so we would
share this mistakes how we acquired how
we treat the culture things how will
five people we should fight some people
earlier we should keep some people you
know there's a lot of detail things I
believe any companies in the church in
the future will learn and and I think
today I'm not talking about Yahoo USA
but we think about how the Internet
companies in the USA and China shall
learn from Yahoo we will all face the
same challenge if we do not learn the
mistakes the other people make so that's
that's how I think I want to share with
the mistakes thank you
hijack I had three quick questions the
first is Java has been incredibly
successful how do you manage and prevent
it from being the victim of its own
success Heidi State nimble you know eBay
itself as sort of stagnated as it got
this large
second is given the competitive
landscape with companies like 360 by
will you be forced to do more on the
logistics side take title will be forced
to what force to build as your own
logistics take title and therefore that
change your model and last is I've read
a lot of things about your account of
what went on with Ali pay it'd be
interesting to hear it if you could do
it over again what would you have hoped
Massa and Jerry would have said to you
how would you have wished that dialogue
would have gone as opposed to the way it
went it actually went okay the first to
tell about yet Taba grows so fast and
will grow even faster in the future the
big challenges that we have never
wronged such a huge company and I don't
believe the internet tenders and PI
thinking I hate the Empire M PI thinking
means join me or I kill you and I don't
like the model I believe the ecosystem
I'm I'm Jo I'm the board member for TNC
that the Nature Conservancy I believe
the the everybody should be connected to
each other helping each other is an
ecosystem so Taobao becomes so big so
fast and i worry about that you're
giving the industry some opportunity
give the competitors some opportunities
so in june we separate the top ball into
four parts because people tell talk to
me is a jack you've been there for nine
years we it's very difficult to compete
with you because you're already so big
okay I make it a smaller you compete
if ten years later I'm still bigger than
that I will put another three pieces
each making sure we run big company like
a small company giving the people the
young people opportunities to run the
business
because it's their business tap out like
a Facebook like a Google like transient
they are not Chinese companies they do
not belong China they do not belong to
us
they belong this time 21st century you
have to use in a different way to run
this company honestly say what is the
best to methodology what is the best
mental thinking to run that company I
don't know we are testing and we're
ready to take mistakes so we believe the
ecosystem we do not believe the empire
thinking so that's why we are testing
everywhere we could and second question
is that leaving the competition 365 yeah
oh you well we're still not all right
change your model
I think they should change their model
it's not that it's not about I don't
feel anything wrong with top our model
where we are growing well we could we
can make money very easily and we can ok
supporting more people so I don't know
we should change our motto and I don't
buy this story about buying things and
selling online this is this is really
stupid bottle all the into that and I
don't like that a logistic things I tell
you last year the total China packs
deliver on the street is 2.1 billion
package delivered topic created nearly
1.1 billion and this year we will
probably create 3 billion package to
live on the street that we do not want
have our own logistic system china
probably needs 10 million people de
living on the street how can we run a
company with 10 minutes employees
right 20,000 people today we have we
have 23,000 people it's already a big
headache it to me so 10 million crazy
nobody can do that
so we should support the logistic
companies to serve well to deliver well
to treat their in price well the custom
well this is what we want to do not we
do not want to have our own logistic
companies never ever so we have the
money we have the inference we have the
orders how we can improve the society
this is and to Aldi pay my son Jerry I
think I have answered that many times
but I can answer you again they are good
friends
they're good partners and I understand
at the beginning say Jack you know how
could you that even today the VI stupor
about it but I got clear messages it yes
I know
so I told them I think today they are
happy now I'm not happy because I'm
getting such a big burden for a leap it
because to the Olly be grow very fast
but it is not a big nice model yet you
cannot make money out of it but we are
supposed to pay that much money at the
end to the company and as a challenge is
a challenge young guys let's create a
good model for that so I think it's a
very healthy discussion between Jerry
Massa and us but unfortunately the room
was out that I moved the company out
with other board a meeting without
notice I tell the truth they know and we
discussed together and today the problem
soft they're happy I'm half burnt
but it's a challenge
shall I place a lot of opportunity no
tough days this is one of the tough
things I have to face because it's easy
for other guys wow you should do this
you do that when you know if Adi paid
die
how about diet if table or die eight
million power cell is in trouble and I
cannot do that
and if I do not follow China law I will
drink a coffee in Beijing every week
everybody wanted me to sit in there and
drinking coffee and you say yeah where
you get a bigger your trouble be
transparent today 21st century
everything should be transparent
otherwise why we should work so hard for
so that's that's I'm telling I think
there's no other way where I can see go
wrong are just to say this is the
reality we have to face it I hope I
answer your question
thank you okay sounds very much for
whenever speech my question is how tell
about evaluate international
collaborations in technology because I
heard about now is they're not open API
for foreign countries I mean non Chinese
countries so it means non Chinese
country is not able to launch their
products based on Taobao platform so I
want to hear your opinion about this
Thanks okay I'd love to we'd love to
open the API for the non Chinese country
unfortunately it's about the payment
it's very difficult I I have you know
when I travel around ourselves so so
many overseas Chinese they say oh top
was one of our camera buy things to
outside China solving and a lot of
foreign we are trying our best and we
think that if the payment prop is soft
things could be moved much faster and
Thapa will never stay alone in China
I said Papa does not belong to China
it comes from China it belongs to the
whole voice belongs to this generation
let's make sure
in the future it can help more people
because things really cool on top ah
thank you thanks so much yeah hi jack
actually my question is kind of similar
whiskers but you wanna buy things from
here to back on top no but of course I
want to rise so chill and thank you to
about improving my life okay so my
question is that you have said that
there is no difficult business in the
world but the truth is for a lot of
foreign company it's really difficult to
do business in China and we have a lot
of clients they want to go to China and
actually luckily top of alloc group can
provide the whole solution for them
actually from the hi China formerly pay
from everything but it's hard for them
to know that there is a choice and it's
hard for them to kind of cross the
policy part of government part so what's
you do you have any plan to help those
foreign companies because Chinese still
has a needs for the flooring products
okay thank you very much
I think doing business is difficulty
anywhere in the world foreign companies
go to China find problems and I think I
now believe Chinese company come to us
and doing business also facing big
problems I don't see any very successful
Chinese companies in USA I mean you know
that we come here in the USA
is there any famous Chinese companies
that come to USA or European that is
very good Oh Oliver now yeah all right
run over do you call that successful
all right my my thinking was that in
China we do have some successful foreign
companies right Microsoft is not bad
iBM is not bad and we have la oracle a
lot of great companies in the foreign
company China very successful guys going
anywhere doing business takes time I
think my friend Kara Fisher you know
asking me about crashing in the D
conference ah
no market welcomes gamblers you go there
create value for local people have time
it will have chance so I believe that
doing business today in everyone world
is difficult China's my wife and I was
debating yesterday morning we're driving
say she's think oh not so difficult to
do business in the USA because there are
the war marching is what happen train
everything's IJ even even the coffee is
that chain is that how can you have a
small business and I said well in the
USA it's easy for a small business to
just to so there's a professor sitting
next to us said we should have a big
debate which country is easier to do
business USC or China and I think China
today if used to think about we should
follow the government Apollo's you know
when she or forget it I've said again
again 12 in the past 12 years every time
I speak out of China if you meet
somebody come to you see I have a strong
friendship with that Mayor forget about
this guy the only one she is the
question with the customer if the
customer love you the government would
better Lee love you trust me they need
attacks Nene the jobs
but if you want to pick around you know
you're in trouble
so I don't I don't believe that because
my relationship with the government in
the past twelve years or so in love with
them don't marry them always I love them
every time they come I tell them the
truth I'll do everything they tell me
yeah okay
right that's communicate but do business
sorry my friend does business with
government not me in this way you get
respect from them if this is that
serious about Ali pay let's listen to
them because the law it's not government
equation so I'll give you advice it's
always scared looking far away oh my god
that's a difficult place go there test
jumping do it you never learn swim until
you're in the water
China is not that bad but but people ask
me why China has knows no Apple USA have
capitalism for more than 200 years right
that sick fertilizers people company die
grow die grow that sick fertilizer China
only 30 years after reformed and
shopping 30 years have a company like a
tears and buy to Alibaba seen it not bad
right so let's wait for another six
thirty years we will have them and that
is not China that belongs the world
because be lost the intern at a time
belongs to the young people who are born
1990s and 1989 year 2000 these are the
people going to change the world and
especially most of the students here and
they are the future but I believe that
thank you
I use the I use the workout event paper
I know how much challenge you have back
to mm I don't know to remember you'll
have the TV advertisement in Australia
that is two months before our Senior
Olympics I have a business if there so
at that time and abhava just to have a
two years old so you'll have the
ambition to have a globalization at that
time so now after ten twelve years right
ah Alabama has a more power to have a
globalization what is your future plan
for the global our growing strategy and
I think that's okay thank you yeah um
you're right when we have money we start
to make mistakes when we have money we
have a beautiful office with high people
with MD MBA degree we hire people is the
vp of multinational companies and and
where we have a little bit money only a
5 minute we start think about
globalization Jesus and then we said
let's back to basic b2c back to China
here 2002
I remove all that time called a b2c back
to China back to basic back to base
right back to central of China the coast
area back to coast area because we that
we tore ourself global vision local wing
no matter how wonderful you think you
have to step on the ground and do the
things that are work every day so so
many years past twelve years past or
stupid leaf global vision local wing but
we start we tested a Japan we tested
Indian we test a European and we tested
also in past twelve year we never shut
down the US office I'm now coming up for
one year I want to learn one thing and I
want to ask this thing to everyone here
sheer fortune 500 CEOs in the world they
all believe China is a big interesting
mark market but nobody really give up
things and come to China to spend one
year there because if you really want to
know China you got to spend some time
and me too and I'm asking us a European
is going to be a big market for us and I
just want to put down everything spend
time in USA for one year get feeling how
we can help the USA SME how we can help
the u.s. what's the difference we can do
between Amazon eBay and us what's the
real value we can create when you think
about that clearly let's start do it
because we cannot have we never should
finish a 20-year program in two years
life is shot the life is long you cannot
say I want to finish that in two years
we have time I'm that old but I'm still
young I I have time yeah so we will go
step by step not asking about how much
revenue we can bring out of China
we will ask what value we really can
bring to local people and we have
already more than 15 million
small business outside China using our
services and we do not charge them and
freedom free is always the best we will
work on that thank you thank you jack
finalize a final I may go see Wanaka a
jolly hahaha COC yeah we did
I just welcome Jack to the u.s. and said
I hope he can have a good rest while
he's here so my question for you is what
do you think is the biggest
misunderstanding that America has about
China and conversely what do you think
is the mega biggest misunderstanding
that China has about America honestly I
don't know that question I think there
are a lot of misunderstanding but I was
thinking about few days ago writing
something on my Weibo everybody believed
that I know the world I know China cos
in completely inside out no you don't
ten sharp into not know Mauser don't do
not know nobody know China and
everything I know USC inside out no you
don't know Obama does not know you're
otherwise people turn us out but George
Cristina no it's very difficult to know
the outside but you know yourself what
do you need what do you want what will
you give up if I know myself better I
can change myself to meet the outside
there's always missing the stand between
China us just like there's always missed
standing between learn and people and
Chinese
right our job is not to solve the mr.
standing our job is to change ourselves
to suit the others so I don't know but
if that's why this is a good passion I'm
coming here because I see so many
American company people think appointed
China and they have never been to China
a lot of Chinese people criticize us
they've never been to the States so if
we do not learn to appreciate each other
to look at the each other and the mole I
spend the state's the more I love USA
and the more I come to China I say well
you know it's it's it's communication
it's so political ice it's political
it's very difficult but there's only one
thing that I think I would be very happy
to do business
I don't like online gaming I think I
believe the best of gaming on the war is
to make money helping small business
cross the ocean doing business make them
understand each other
my grandfather no news by reading
newspaper my father
no news by listening to the radio our
generation
no the world by watching TV our kids
know the world by the internet they say
I want to involve and I believe this is
the time let's speed up internet
anything happened the USA we know in
China immediately anything happy in
China most of the things you know very
quickly
well let's don't laugh let's appreciate
most of the things let's appreciate that
doing things step by step is important
instead of get everything one night
thank you
last one yeah sorry jack you you
mentioned that you spent some time here
in the early days of Alibaba and that
you were rejected by a lot of venture
capitalists who you met with but there
was one investor here in Silicon Valley
who played a big role in Alibaba success
which was Jerry Yang and Yahoo who
invested I believe a billion dollars
into Alibaba in 2005 can you talk about
your relationship with Jerry how that
investment came about and what your
relationship was like with him now and
how integral that investment has been to
alibaba's growth and success okay first
Jerry is a very good friend of mine
personal friend lifetime longtime friend
where families also good friends and but
it's nothing personal it's all about
business right Yahoo is invested as your
2005 I think a benefit of both sides
rosada Yahoo US investment we would not
be that successful today because we need
to will not need a cache to solve our
problem we need that cash to solve the
venture capital problem they do not see
Alibaba has a future they want to cash
up so they help us that not on the
business side mainly and without Yahoo
deal we will never learn how to partner
with a big company what's the big
company's problem how we can improve our
own culture and things but in the future
if with today's situation we do not a
change we will not have a bright future
we have to do something so I think
fairly speaking we appreciate yesterday
but we are looking for a better tomorrow
every company should do that and today
and Jerry and you know we're still
pretty close friends and we talk with
chat we'll play golf baby in the future
the same and we like we like yeah
I think this is Yahoo is the company at
least one of the three companies that
awake
wake me up about Internet and I
appreciate that all my life without
internet there will be no Jack Ma and
there will be no Alibaba talbo so that's
what I'm my own C's thank you very much
we have time I think I think Cara has a
question from all things decent it's
your friend Kara Swisher yes how are you
doing so two quick questions so you
talked about you're interested in buying
Yahoo one have you visited Yahoo on this
trip and two how are you going to buy
Yahoo we just invited by a passer-by
crushing in a very honest away first
class you know I've been here for 15
days yeah and most of time sleeping and
reading no I don't have time to I think
sleeping is more important now then
because they're gonna be tough long way
to go second your question is about how
we are interested in getting the whole
the whole yeah toe piece the whole piece
of your of your Yahoo China steak or the
whole piece of all of Yahoo o piece of
Yahoo Yahoo China is already our ours
right it's already in my pocket right
the only thing I got to say is thank you
and all this confusion for the first
crystal clear answer about Yahoo about
the company I appreciate it as a
reporter so when's that going to happen
I don't know honestly I don't know
because it's it's more complicated than
we thought and there are so many people
are interested in that and we're also
talking to them and they are talking to
us and we think that it's it's it's I
was told it's so difficult it's not by
money Susan it's by political issue
anxiety so small you know so I cross my
finger just to say we are very very
interesting that okay perfect thanks
yeah